- Good serve.
- Thank you very much.
- Brilliant, that was.
Hello, the internet. I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- We're the slow-mo guys.
And sometimes something
happens on the internet.
It ends up on Reddit, and
Reddit beckons us forth.
- We took a picture of some jelly.
Jello, whatever it is.
It's being cut up by a tennis
racket when it was hitting it
into the little squares, you see here.
So we're going to try to emulate
that here in slow motion.
See if we can get the whole thing.
- It's basically a still picture.
We're gonna do the slow-mo in it.
We've got a variety of
colors and we're going
to start with red.
- That's some lovely red.
- All right, what are the
chances this will go right
the first time.
- Absolutely not.
We've got five for a reason,
it wasn't for different
colors, it's because I'm
going to mess this up.
I've never hit jelly before.
- It's like a jelly fish.
- Quick, for me man.
- Hang on.
- It's gonna stick to my hands.
When I chuck it up, it's
gonna stick to my hand.
Oh God, quick, go.
Ready?
Good lord.
- Need to film it better,
but perfect concept.
- Now I'm gonna go for a tight one.
- Yup.
Which, you have to be really
precise where you hit it.
- I'll try.
- It's gotta be right in that window.
So getting this in frame and in focus.
It's gonna be relatively difficult.
So if you can nail that,
it will be class shot.
It will be absolutely wonderful.
Ready.
Not bad on focus.
Wicked.
Oh man.
They're like individual snakes.
- Yeah.
- That's like a quick way to
make a bunch of gummy worms.
- Imagine that's what
they do in factories.
- Rack it there.
- So far, all we've done is
replicate the picture we saw.
- Yeah.
- Feel like it wouldn't be
a slow-mo guys video if we
didn't add some what of
a slow-mo touch to it.
- I see where this is going.
- Where's it going?
- I'm gonna get covered
in jelly or something.
- What are the chances I'm
going to completely miss?
- Quite high.
Yeah, I feel like I'm underneath a grater.
Come on.
- Did it work?
- It's all over your face.
- My eyebrows, my eyelids
are like struggling to move
because it's all sticky.
Oh it's horrible.
Oh, this is so munging.
- It looks incredible though.
- My eyebrows, my eyelashes
are all stuck together
I really wanna go and wash my face off.
- You know when your
fingers are all sticky?
- Oh this is annoying.
- I imagine this is way worse than that.
- It's all over my arm
hair, my joint hairs are all
sticking together.
- Oh you got some snacks on
your shoulder, have a little
bit of that.
- Went down my throat.
I sucked it up and it went up in there.
- So thanks to those on
Reddit who sent that to us
or tweet that to us that
said we should re-create it.
Feel free to do that in future.
We'll do it as soon as possible.
You can subscribe to us on Twitter.
You can buy shirts.
- Jelly covered t-shirt.
Shirt singers.
And we've got posters as well.
- Fancy.
To every new upload, subscribe.
Hit the little bell thing on the app.
It's all good.
Stay informed.
Stay in school.
Slow-mo guys.
- I'm gonna go in and shower,
this is absolutely munging.
Can't stand this.
- Slow mo guys.
- Before this video ends,
I just wanna give a lovely
shout out to the guys
at New Egg who offered
to send me a bunch of PC
parts for me to build a
new PC.
I'll be using it to store
and convert phantom footage.
Way faster than I could before.
So if you're building a
PC, be sure to check out
New Egg, the links in the description.
Thanks!